hi mom Chloe welcome home so is
everything set for dads surprise party
he got called into work can I buy you a
coffee
I'm waiting for someone oh my dad hi
sweetheart
welcome aboard pan-con fly to five-seven
to london by x day will be six hours and
three minutes
people from all over this planet simply
vanished Chris
I know you all want answers and believe
me so do I and I'll do my best to get
them
I heard some doctors talking it's not
just here it's all for the world one of
these days discuss
Chloe are you okay yeah mom and Ramey
they're both gotten yeah
Irene knew this was coming it's the way
it happened how could she know that he
took them to protect them from the
darkest time in the history of this
world
Oh God my mother talked about would
never do something like this
right you know we're gonna die die
no spoiler there's no flaps no elevators
and if I run this thing Brian no reverse
watch I need some
I just released me didn't know how much
I love you what happens
looks like the end of the world one of
these days the sky's gonna break and
everything